[Music]
hey kids it's me Kevin Smith man and
we're still out there on the convenience
tour still taking clerks three around
there's not that many shows left we
started September 4th we end on December
6th
um this if you're curious what do they
do when they're out there on the road
what is he up to was he was he building
in there if you were curious this is
what it looks like we've we've been
taking questions we've been marrying
people we've been having a good ass time
on the convenience tour look
question
um now that Weeds now legal in Jersey
um have you thought about I don't know
why I'm sorry I'm so used to normally
when I'm out of place I'm on the stage
and stuff but here I'm on the floor and
it's like why I could come right up to
you
we could have like a conversation give
me your hand [ __ ] yes
I took the drive as me uh Josh and Liv
my tour managers took the drive from
last night we were in Saint Paul
Minnesota and took the ride down here
and and uh well
thank you
they can't hear you I
[Applause]
so we took the drive down man and
I got to tell you it's pretty [ __ ]
harrowing
because there are so many [ __ ] dead
deer on the side of the road
[Applause]
like we're you know we normally drive we
sing at the top of our lungs and [ __ ]
like that and [ __ ] we could not get a
song going because we were like [ __ ]
yeah oh
oh you know most of them just kind of
look like they're sleeping poorly like
but every once in a while you find one
where it's like turned inside and you're
like God damn it and you start [ __ ]
thinking of your own mortality and
you know like he was somebody's baby and
[ __ ] like that oh it's so [ __ ] bad so
we stopped
we're driving get some gas and [ __ ] and
we were in the convenience store and we
were talking about three it was like oh
my God the amount of [ __ ] dead deer
on the road and [ __ ] and the guy behind
the counter goes oh you've seen all the
deer
and I was like you can't help but see
all them deer man and he goes yeah I
believe the Wisconsin state flag has a
dead deer on the side of the road on it
and I legit laughed I was like that's
[ __ ] funny man
and he goes well that means a lot coming
from a pro and I was just like oh well
thank you he goes thank you Kevin James
and then that was that
[Applause]
did you think did you record that yeah
so exciting
it's magic
that's the best part of the whole
[ __ ] tour we didn't come here for the
Jay and Silent Bob reboot Road Show tour
for some reason we went to a casino and
[ __ ] River
which was absolutely lovely as the home
birthplace of uh Captain Kirk was from
there
um but it was weird I've never had this
happen before so uh at one point they
were like so what is the show and we
were like oh I get up and I intro and
then uh we uh show the movie and then
afterwards get back up we do q a and the
Q a is almost as long as the [ __ ]
movie
and they were like okay when is the
intermission and I was like there never
is one uh once I start talking I only
stopped to let the movie talk and then
after that I go back to talking instead
I was like I love the sound of my own
voice so it's quite an evening for me
and they were like well this is a casino
I was like I noticed I saw the you know
[ __ ] machines and [ __ ] like that
and now they were like yeah but people
got to gamble and like go buy drinks
otherwise why the [ __ ] did we bring you
here and [ __ ]
I was like I don't know because clerks I
I
you know like so you gotta have a an
intermission I was like what do you mean
they're like about halfway through the
movie you have an intermission everyone
gets to go out get drinks Gamble and
then come back and watch the rest of the
movie an hour later and I was like kids
like there's almost no point in doing
the movie if that's the case I mean it
would make more sense to like have the
movie and then have a break and then
have the Q a and they're like oh okay
can you do that and I was like no uh
I've never done that I want to go off
the [ __ ] Vibe of the flick man I want
to go right after the flavor be weird if
like we do it like an hour later and
they were like well what do we do here
and I was like I I don't know man I hear
you Iowans are stubborn but [ __ ]
get it um okay so uh I was texting with
my mom and uh I was like hey um she goes
where are you now tiger and I said I'm
in Dallas we're about to show clerks at
the Texas theater and uh she was she was
like um Texas theater isn't that where
Lee Harvey Oswald was arrested because
my father is a big history buff so my
mother knows a lot about a very specific
point in history anything my father knew
my mother knows so if I ask her about
like ma what's going on today in the
world she'd be like no clue because my
old man's been dead for 20 years so
there's nobody to fill her in and [ __ ]
but this [ __ ] she knows any JFK [ __ ] she
[ __ ] knows I was like uh yeah I said
this is the place and and I wrote I'm
not a patsy because that's what he
I'm just a patsy that's what he said
when he was being dragged out I'm just a
patsy and um my mom's my mom's like um
no one calls you a patsy tiger and I
said um but on the internet Ma on
Twitter yesterday they called me a cuck
and she goes uh why and I was like
because I put up a picture of me uh
crying after seeing the Black Panther
sequel wakanda forever and my mom goes
well what is a [ __ ]
and I had the most awkward moment
explaining it to her and then there's a
long [ __ ] pause and my mother goes
hot
thank you
she's got some insight into Grace man at
age 76 she's like that sounds hot
which now makes me rethink my father
completely man
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
bringing it home
all right oh my God seems like you
overpaid for
what a workout
all right kids let's practice
um I uh have done this before many times
uh this is kind of uh sacred uh we're
all here for something uh amazing you're
going to watch two people become one you
came to see a [ __ ] the third clerks
movie
you had no idea you were going to watch
a true [ __ ] miracle man because
that's what marriage is an absolute
[ __ ] miracle you ask anyone who's
been divorced they'll tell you
it's an absolute [ __ ] Miracle Man uh
now folks we're about to get religious I
know some people don't like that sort of
thing God makes them uncomfortable or
whatnot but we got to do this in order
to get through in order to bind you
together holy words must be spake and
those holy words are about to happen now
you ready for that in Brightest Day
in Brightest Day in Blackest Night in
Blackest Night no evil shall Escape my
sight no evil shall Escape my sight let
those who worship evils might let those
who worship evil Smite beware my power
beware my power
Green Lantern's light
the power invested in me by the
Universal Life Church kids
I Now Pronounce You man and wife Robin
and Tyler kiss each other hard
declare Ryan and Jennifer man and wife
you may kiss the bride
so sad that it's all going to come to an
end doesn't that all seem like good
times it was I lived it and it was good
times man life on the convenience tour
has been nothing but bliss kids and
sadly it's all coming to a close man so
if you're in one of the Cities that's
left man uh San Antonio uh
Phoenix Boston or Hartford we're on our
way and then we wrap it all up what a
magical time it's been I'll never forget
all this never forget all you who are on
the [ __ ] tour man ones I married the
ones I didn't marry uh because there
were more of those than the ones I
married
here it is kids from uh the road from uh
right now we're in Austin Texas the
Paramount Theater uh from the
convenience tour I'm Kevin Smith uh
saying you are supposed to be here today
remember the movie
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old I'm Kevin
Smith
[Music]